Good evening.
In the last session we looked at
how to compute or estimate the
dissimilarity between complex
object.
So we have, uh, when we look at
very simple objects in the sense
that object with only one
attribute.
So in that case we are very
comfortable getting the
distances and similarities.
Particularly if it is numeric.
So for example, if you say that
there are three people and their
ages are 2027 and 54, so you got
a picture of what is similar,
what is dissimilar and how much
is the distance.
Everything you got in your mind,
but most of the time in data
science when you deal with the
data objects, they don't come
out that simple.
So they come with the 2000
attributes so many many
attributes.
It can be ten 2000 or it can be
much larger it depending on the
type of problem.
Scientific problem or whatever
that you are dealing with.
Uh, so in such cases it you
cannot think of similarity and
dissimilarity like the way we
thought when the object had only
one attribute, we thought we
know nothing about the three
people other than the age.
And we want to use the age to
come back.
So it was much easier for easier
task for us.
So we have seen that the
attributes are divided into 3
categories.
When we wanted to compute the
similarity or dissimilarity,
first one was categorical and
one type of variant within the
categorical was ordinal and
another variant of the
categorical is the binary and
the binary can be symmetric or
asymmetric.
So in all these three types of
attributes we have seen how to
compute the dissimilarity or
similarity?
Someone said something or not
for me, OK?
Then we have seen that for
numeric it is, it is it showing
that there is no scaling
required scaling we are going to
talk about in a short way.
So we can simply compute the
difference or or the distance
and similarity can be something
opposite of that.
So what is the which has got the
lesser distance?
That's what we may say.
It's more similar.
So, so now let's go into the
previous session where we looked
at, we looked at the proximity
measures for the we have seen
for the categorical attributes
then and ordinal attributes, a
nominal attributes, ordinal
attributes, binary attributes,
then numeric attributes.
And finally, we said that when
we come to the complex
attributes objects, we need to
find a way to combine all their
effects because all the
attributes are contributing
something to this similarity or
dissimilarity.
So we need to add them up.
So how do we add them up?
So adding up is actually very it
can be very simple.
And she let us assume that among
all the attributes we are
getting the distance measured in
the same scale.
So in that case, what we can do
is that we can think in directly
in terms of.
So we have many attributes.
We have many attributes, each
one of them is contributing.
Let's generalize this.
OK, let's generalize this.
So A1 is contributing a distance
of D1.
OK, attribute A1 can be nominal
binary or anything is
contributing distance B2.
OK.
And between two objects this is
the distance we are computing
and a three is contributing D3.
So how do I combine the
difference?
So what I will do is that W 1 *
D One indicating that for
attribute one I want to give a
weightage bless W2.
I want to give a different
weightage to attribute to bless.
Different weight is to attribute
3 and then I combine all of that
and then I sum up W1 plus W2
plus W and of course it is
possible that W1W 2W3 all are
equal to 1.
In that case, the problem is
much simpler.
So how did we compute we
computed using these measures,
so let us look at a simple
example to see how are we going
to combine the distance measure
among the data object.
So here we have four data
objects, right?
We have four data objects and we
have 3 attributes.
One is color, which is
categorical or nominal and
quality, which is ordinal and
some quantity, and we don't know
what the object is.
So let's take some quantity
number and what we will do is
that we want to put the distance
of each one of them in the scale
of zero to 1.
I'm I'm checking I'm seeing
someone is trying to speak.
Yeah, Sir.
Like I had to doubt for previous
class.
So for calculating the distance
whenever there is 2 attribute
Hmm.
and when we go when we die
scalate the distance suppose for
row two then row three no.
Hmm.
If you it's a row three, row two
and column three.
So for first call first column
we will only take the attribute
of the first one and for the
second, second column we will
take in consideration for both
the attributes right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, not like
that, Mister.
Like a.
Amit, what we have done is that
in last class we have simplified
the problem.
We looked at one attribute at a
time.
The.
We did not look at so.
So what we did is 1 attribute
and then we said all attributes
are of the same type.
2nd.
Then how do we merge?
We never thought about when the
attributes are of different
type.
So suppose binary attributes
are, they said we said 10 binary
attributes are there out of them
two attributes.
Both of them have same value and
in three attributes one is
having one other is having zero.
So we thought about same
attribute types and for that we
have tried to combine a Mr Amit
Army In Sync or Ms Sing
something.
Yeah.
Yes, Sir.
So.
So just let me let me go to 1
slide very quickly to explain.
So what we did was that for this
is a numeric attributes.
So what we did is that this is
an asymmetric binary attributes,
so we counted the attributes,
all the attributes other than
the gender we said before
gender.
We will not consider because
that is symmetric, so only for
asymmetric binary attributes
which are six.
So we consider the distance of
the rows.
We consider the entire row, but
job versus Jim, then Jim versus
Mary A Mr Amit, are we In Sync
now?
Yes, Sir.
OK.
OK, OK.
So can I proceed further?
Yes, Sir.
Yeah.
Let me proceed this.
So I hope things get clear as
you look at the example I I'm
sure.
Yeah.
OK, so now let us look at let us
look at the complex object.
So object one has got 3
attributes, but each attribute
is of a different type.
Each attribute of a different
type, so we need to combine.
So for color, we have seen the
categorical attribute.
How to compute the distance and
the ordinal attribute we have?
We know how to compute the
distance.
Be in the.
Ohh.
Hello.
I'm hearing AC of myself.
What one of them?
Yeah, one but.
Yes, I'm gonna return unmute and
they are muted back.
Yeah, someone has.
OK.
OK, then what I will do is I let
me mute everybody for a few
You can go ahead.
minutes and then I will.
I will unmute you after some
time so that we can have a
discussion.
So now let me I will unmute you
after I complete this example.
OK, So what we are saying is
that an object one has three
attributes.
All the objects have 3
attributes and we want to
compute the distance, so the
distance with what we will do is
that what we know is how to
compute the distance for each
type of attribute.
So for color, we know whether it
matches.
It is 00.
The distance is 0 when they
don't match, distance is 1, so
you can see the distance matrix
4 color.
Only color.
OK, this is the distance metric.
Then for quality, we know that
this is an ordinal variable.
We need to compute a jet score.
Jet score is from the range of 0
to one, so there are three
grids.
Fair, good and excellent.
So fair will be 0.
Excellent.
Will be one and good will be .5
and now we compute the distance.
Then for numeric what we do is
that the numeric is in a big
scale, so again we want to bring
it to 0 to one.
So what we do is that we do a
min Max normalization.
So what we do is that anytime
there is a distance, we divide
it by the distance of maximum to
minimum.
So in that case, what is going
to happen?
So we are going to see the min
Max normalization.
This will be the min Max
normalization when we see the
distance is 4/7 object one is
475 and object two is 0 object
one is 475 object two is 0.
So and maximum is 100, minimum
is 10.
Sorry Maxim is 1000 and minimum
is 10, so we use this formula to
compute.
So did 21.
Is this similarly D31 is we
compute D3000 and D1 is 475, so
1000 -.
475 / 1000 -.
10 so we get a value.
Similarly, we get all the
distance matrix entire distance
matrix.
Now the job is to combine the
three, so we got the distance
matrix for color distance matrix
for quality distance matrix.
For quantity, we combine all
this and get the distance.
And here we assume that the
weights for all the distances
are seen.
OK, so if we want to use a
different weights, so we are
going to get different answers.
So finally after completing all
the distances dissimilarities.
So this is what we are going to
get at.
So we can say that when we
combine the all the distances,
what are the two most similar
objects?
So we have to say one and four
seem to be most similar because
they have the minimum distance
and which are the objects with
the maximum distance.
So it seems like two and three
have the maximum distance, so
you can see point 88338.33 and
the other ones have one has
eight point .8 through and other
one is .8 through 2.
Three, slightly smaller, but the
maximum is with two, three so so
you can see whether you can make
that out.
Looking at the objects that 2-3
are having, the maximum distance
and 1/4 are closest, so I hope
you are able to make that out.
Looking at the data and then all
our methods are giving a
reasonable results because you
are finding this data, the
results are consistent with what
you observe.
I hope so.
So let me unmute you people and
for a couple of minutes because
I'll after that we will
continue.
So.
So let me let me unmute people.
So I hope you are able to see
that.
Uh.
The one object one and object
four, which are looking similar.
They are also showing up in the
distance matrix with the minimum
distance .0083 and object two
and object three are having the
maximum distance, though there
is no distinct winner here
because there are three object,
one to two also has a
significant distance and object
two to four also got significant
distance.
But you can see that. Yeah.
Are there two to three got me
maximum distance in this table.
Why would you?
OK, so so that is how we proceed
with the distance computation.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
Right said I'm VISHAL here.
Let me show you how to compute
it.
UH-11 question.
Yeah.
You OK?
Open quote.
You, you you have a question
alright? Yes.
I said just one thing.
So like.
Set the means there is a one and
four is more are more similar
because they are matching color
and matching the quality.
Right.
Right, right.
That is what we are seeing,
right?
Is that how?
Because, see, we are there is a
mathematical formula obviously
with hundred dimensional data we
may not even be able to visually
tell that, but we are all we are
saying is that we can be
confident that our method is
working.
You look at the distance and we
have done it entirely
mathematically and we got a
distance which seems reasonable.
Are you are we In Sync?
That that I.
OK.
That after we calculated these
three types like how we are
Yes, Sir.
merging all three.
Yes, we got the all the
distances in the scale of 0 to
one and now what we do is that
we use this formula, right?
We use this formula.
You can see so use the weighted
sum and the weightages we used
is same for all the distance.
We use the same weightage and we
have computed look at the
computation in this case.
OK.
So is there a case where like
where this will be different?
Yes.
See that depends on your domain
knowledge, because for example,
if you are in a medical domain,
you think that one symptom has
to be given more weight is.
So I mean, we obviously that is
that is for the domain expert to
decide.
And we are dividing by the total
weight.
Yes, yes, total weight because
again, we want to normalize it
and bring it to 0 to one scale.
Thank you.
So so the denominator.
Sir, how did we try this color
and quality metrics?
Uh, uh, OK, I I'm not getting
the question.
What is the question about the
color and?
The color and the quality
metrics is you drive right?
So this one zero.
Yes, yes, that we derived it
earlier that that we have
Sorry 01.
derived using the same method
that we had used in the last
class when it is a categorical
object.
If they are matching, we are
giving a distance of 0.
If they do not match, we are
giving a distance of 1.
If there are many categorical
attributes, so we are just
simply taking how many of them
matching and how many of them
are mismatching and accordingly
we are normalizing it.
And the quality and when it is
an ordinal variable, we are
What is it?
Yeah.
converting it into jet score and
computing the distance.
Then why are we keep that
quantity?
Like that quantity matrix?
Mr B, can you repeat the
question?
Quantity 1.
The quantity matrix, whatever we
derived.
Quantity.
The quantity is a numerical
thing, so for example it is a
salary or weight or something
like that.
So there the range can be
significant.
So we are doing a min Max
normalization that puts the
distance into the range of 0 to
one.
So the min Max normalization
formula we have seen is that is
that the question Missouri.
So this the question is about
the normalization that we are
Yes, yes.
doing, right?
So.
Mr Rubik, please speak is the is
your question?
I'm answering your question.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, Sir.
Yes, Sir.
OK, OK.
So you so you can see the
computation for the min, Max
normalization.
So the distance we are computing
by taking the difference and
dividing it by the distance of
the maximum value to minimum
value.
So, Sir, in case if that is the
case, if we still have in
quantity, we have like 4 set,
you know across 400 to 500.
Yes.
Yes, tell me.
Yeah, so now here it is like
10,000.
You know the variance is so
huge, but however, if it is in
future, if it is like around 400
to 450 then how do we do it?
Even then we do normalization.
We can do this three.
No, no.
You can look at the formula.
This formula is never going to
fail because you are taking.
Suppose you got million records,
but even in the million records
you are taking the maximum value
and minimum value and then every
other distance your computing
using by scaling with the Max to
me Max minus min.
So why will it change?
For example, India population,
let us say, the minimum age is
0.
So newborn kit and the maximum
age in India is that let's say
125 or so.
OK, so now anytime your age is
suppose 30 and my age is 40 so
40 -, 30 is 10 but we are
dividing it by 125 -, 0.
So it will never be crossing
one.
So we are always normalizing it
by the maximum range.
Are we In Sync or are you
missing?
Are are we missing something?
No, Sir, I'm not too sure. So.
So let's say for example,
considering the example of
collecting the documents per
individual employee in an
organization, then if that is
the case, quantity will be like.
OK. Hmm.
Assume that there are hundred
documents.
The quantity can be same right
for all the employees then min,
OK.
No, in that case you don't call
it a numeric measure, so when
Max.
all the employees you're
collecting 100 documents, why do
you compute that as a major for
discriminating between
employees?
Because here you are talking
about how to discriminate
between two things.
For example, one customer is
having a different taste and
other customer is different.
So you want to discriminate
saying that I will sell this
product to that customer and
this customer will not like this
OK.
product.
Are you understanding this
because the idea of a distance
Got it, got it. OK.
is that you want to discriminate
saying that this person is
likely to catch a disease, but
this person will not catch the
all.
The idea is distinguished, but I
don't know in your example how
Makes sense.
does that work OK.
No, no, I I got it.
And and what is that?
What is that we have taken in
the denominator one into one,
into one in the next slide, that
is that is that three next next
Next slide.
This slide right is this the
slide.
one, Sir, next one.
Next slide.
This is the one.
Yeah, the weights are all equal.
We said weights are all equal 1
so, but the weight can be
OK.
different.
OK.
If we think some attribute is
more import.
Got it.
Alright, so now we got the how
to compute the distance between
the complex objects.
So now let us look at another
way to compute the the
similarity.
So this is when we have a high
dimensional data.
This is very helpful high
dimensional data.
And we are looking at, for
example, the data is such that
it can be all the attributes,
all attributes.
Thanks.
Sorry Sir.
What do we mean by high
dimensional data?
We know two dimensional data.
Many attributes. Many
attributes.
Suppose the object has got 100
dimensions or 100 attributes.
OK, OK.
Each attribute is considered as
a dimension.
OK.
All attributes are numeric, OK
and in that case in that case.
So a good approach is to go with
cosine similarity.
For this measures the similarity
so in two dimensional space I'll
put it like this.
Suppose that there is a vector
E.
Then there is a vector B.
Then we have a vector C so we
can say that there is a greater
similarity between A&B
compared to A and C.
So that is the idea, because we
are seeing we are looking at the
cosine angle.
So when based on the cosine
computation, so we are seeing
that.
So now let us look at how to how
do we compute.
Suppose that there is a.
There are some documents and
then we are we are we are
representing the documents based
on the keywords important words
that they have.
So now let us say our intention
is to look at the documents.
These are all sports documents
and we are we are looking at the
similarities of the document
because we think that these are
the important discriminators
between the the presence or
absence of these words.
We'll discriminate those
documents.
So in such case so we can we can
see that we can represent a
document by a by the count of
the terms.
So we are representing document
by the term frequency.
Term frequency.
So we got 1234510 terms.
So for each of the terms, we are
looking at the frequency and
then this vector.
What we are doing is we are
taking a cosine measure which is
a dot product divided by the the
absolute value of the vector
absolute value of the vector is
computed using the Euclidean
approach.
So we take the square and take
the square root.
So now let us see how do we
compute the distance of 2/2
documents?
D1 is this which is you can see
5030200200 and then D2 is 3020
then 1101G1.
So how do we compute the
similarity so we take a dot
product dot product is that you
you multiply the corresponding
term frequency, so the term one
is term 1 is what team team is
having five in presence in
document one and document 2-3
so.
So you for that term we are
multiplying.
So essentially these are
representing the multiple
attributes.
So we are saying that it is each
document is represented by 10
attributes and so attribute to
one has a value of five for
document one and document two is
3.
So when you do a dot product
where you simply multiply all of
them and add them up, then it
will be and then to get a cosine
you have to divide with the the
documents vector site vector
size.
How do you compute so you simply
compute using the using this
diagonal measure.
So what we are saying is that
along each dimension we take the
square and then for the
summation of the square we take
the root.
So when we take combine the
square of five plus square of
three plus square of two and
square of two that comes out to
be 42, then we take the root of
that.
We are getting 6.481.
Similarly for D2, we maintain,
we compute the size of the
vector which comes to 4.12.
So cosine of B1 and B2 will come
out as this is.
This is actually 25 / 6.481 *
4.1, so this is what is the.
I hope this is clear.
Uh said how you get the cosine
means this formula means any
I mean the formula is something
the cosine is see for two
definition of this formula.
First line of the one and G2.
dimensions.
You can easily visualize it is
the angle between the vector you
plot the two points and you plot
the vector from 00 OK and then
the angle will come out.
So if it is A2 dimensional data,
it is easy to visualize, but it
applies even for high
dimensional data.
Mr VISHAL.
Arvin. Sync.
Yeah.
OK, OK.
That is, we are going to find
the angle between the two
vectors.
Yes, yes, yes.
So so it is it is.
It comes from that dot product
divided by the the vectors
magnitudes.
Yeah, magnitudes of the both the
both 30 can say vectors.
Right.
So basically we are considering
like a for this.
If I have to correlate it
mathematically, the inner
product space we are considering
the DOT product as the inner
product space and then we are
like doing the dot product of
two vectors so that to find out
the angle between them right?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
In fact, the DOT product and
before doing the dot product we
are normalizing it by the vector
size so that the vector is not
Sir.
going to arbitrary values.
But it is normalized to say all
the values come between zero and
one, so that is how we are,
yeah.
And the and this norm is
Nickelodeon norm, right?
Yeah, you cloudian norm.
Yes, that is right.
So that is what we are dividing
it by the Euclidean norms so
So.
that the vector gets normalized,
right?
OK. OK.
Thank you.
It means it means the value if
it is closer to closer to one,
it means more similarity, right
and 0 means less.
Yeah, absolutely.
That is correct.
When it is closer to 1 because
it is cosine is 0 degrees, is 1
You know, means Lesson Realty.
and cosine 90 degrees is 0, yes.
OK, OK.
And then Theta is equal to Cos
inverse of that value then we
get that degree.
No, no.
But we we don't generally go
into Theta compute the Theta.
OK, OK.
We are happy with the because
finally again our intention is
OK, OK.
to do a discrimination.
So we are saying that what are
similar things?
What are dissimilar things?
Because that helps to solve our
data science problems.
So you, you we have already seen
examples of data science
problems.
So our intention is more of for
example, I hope you remember the
OK.
1st as we talked about who is
going to vote for the Republican
Party and who is going to work
for vote for Democratic Party.
So now our intention is
discriminate the people if many
attributes are corresponding to
the democratic principles and
many attributes of the voter is
matching with the Republican
expectations, then fine, we have
already discriminated and now we
will put them into the correct
bracket.
And then we solved our problem.
Because our problem as a data
scientist is to tell what is the
likelihood percentage that these
people will get.
Makes sense of things.
OK, so now let us proceed with
the how do we handle the numeric
data we have already seen one
way of handling the numeric data
is to do a min Max
normalization.
So now let us see more generic
approach of what all things that
we can possibly do.
So now let me let me go into.
Going to the new file.
Uh, said one.
So first thing is that we can
convert.
When?
Just a small question.
Yes.
Yeah.
So I'm saying that like
previously we we studied just
before the cosine similarity
which we we we studied the
another can we get the scenarios
or something where that which
scenario we will use the cosine
similarity on the previous
theorem like this one.
I see.
See in both because one thing I
told you in cosine similarity
applies only in limited context.
When you have all the numeric
attributes and you can represent
it like a normal vector with all
of them are scaled in the same
way.
But if it is a complex
attribute, for example you are
Umm.
taking two people and you're
considering one is the gender
and other is the profession, and
then you are considering the age
and then education and maybe
many other criteria.
So obviously the you cannot
create a cosine, right?
Umm.
OK, OK.
So if we there is a OK, go
ahead.
Said one quick.
Go ahead VISHAL, go ahead.
I will go after you.
OK.
Thank you.
So means if means means whatever
we data data we captured.
If there is a no relation
between them or you say that our
relation between them so that we
are choosing that, how we will
calculate the distance and how
we will calculate cosine
similarities?
Maybe you have to help me and
and I I do not think I got it
exactly.
Some or somebody else wants to
answer his question.
Means if I want to ask that if
we capture the data in that they
have a means having a some means
of a single person.
We have a like a color like age
and there is a very close
relation or something like from
medical like these a person that
OK.
so and the cosine, cosine we are
taking that uh means maybe that
there is a not not much of a
single person or something like
that.
No, no, no.
It is a single person, single
data object.
So.
Umm.
Let us forget about person.
OK. Umm.
Even if we are comparing 2
products, for example two cars,
you will take the same approach.
OK, so now the question is that
the cosine will work only for
OK.
all the attributes have got the
same type.
The numeric type and they can
all be scaled right?
OK.
So but if it is not, then you
cannot use cosine.
Mr VISHAL, are we in Singh?
OK.
OK. OK.
Now, yeah, OK, now I understood
that like there you take in that
it's a male female that is a not
a numeric data.
They then you cannot reuse a
cosine.
And here.
Here cosine here.
They yes.
OK.
OK, got it.
OK.
Thank you very much Sir.
Yes.
So one person you know?
Said I have a question.
Ohh Mr Santosh, go ahead. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yes, I'm in actually, in
parallel.
We are also having a same
concept discussed in
mathematics, so it is inline to
that just to concrete my
understanding.
So when we say similarity, does
it means that these vectors that
we are finding the similarity
they fall in the same plane
mathematically and the
dissimilar?
Ohh Mr Santosh.
No, no, no, no.
Just one minute.
The I I I'm sure in mathematics
they will explain it that way,
but let me explain it in another
way.
Suppose that you have been hired
by some agency to say in
American voters how many voters
are going to vote for Republican
Party and how many are going to
vote for Democratic Party.
You somehow have to solve the
problem.
Is it not?
You need to distinguish the
people.
Are they likely to fit into one
basket or the other?
So so is this clear?
And I and I I was trying to just
concrete the.
So now obviously if there is a
maximum distance, you know that
the these two people are, surely
they're going to vote for
different parties.
Umm.
Order or it can be something
like when you got a really fancy
gadget.
So you you were company is
launching a fancy gadget and
among the customers you want to
choose who is likely to buy?
Suppose you already have some
sample of customers who are
likely to buy.
So obviously if another customer
is there that details do not
match simply with the customers
who are buying it.
So you are not going to send a
brochure and you are not going
to send a salesperson to that
persons house to demonstrate the
product.
Right.
Mr Santosh, are we In Sync?
Right, yes.
So that is what the data
scientist is possibly the
organization looks up the data
scientist for saying that.
Can you organize the data in
such a way that it helps us
making the decisions?
Alright.
Mr Santosh, are we In Sync or am
I losing?
And I understood your point,
Sir, and just trying to tie up
what we have learned
mathematically, but it's OK.
No, no.
I'm sure in mathematics they may
be talking in same terms, but
now if you bring in a plane and
you want me to explain it in A3
dimensional plane and all that.
So I don't want to go into that.
So.
So The thing is that yes, so The
thing is that that will help.
Sure, sure. OK.
That will surely plane is
important concept but but our
intention is to to get these
things so that we will go into
the algorithms because our
intention is not to stop with
the distance because our
intention is that once you
understand the distance then we
will help you.
But we will start discussing the
algorithms that will that will
be helpful for solving various
types of problems that data
scientists can will be coming
across.
Right.
Thank you, Sir.
No.
So that and the previous slide,
so that from the value that .94
so which means it has that that
much similarity that comparing
the tool document right.
That is correct.
Yes, similarity, right?
So if it is that is like 90%
similarity .94.
Not 90%.
We don't go that way, but then
compare the similarity and then
say that if the similarity of
.94 is better than the
similarity of .85.
So.
So saying that because see for
example let us go back to the
again the problem.
So we you have to sell for your
company makes fancy gadgets and
you got the list of customers
who are likely to like who have
already bought that fancy
gadget.
It's a very expensive gadget.
Let's say it costs 5,00,000 and
and it it is liked by only
people with certain
characteristics.
So now the point is that you
have got a customer database of
some other million customers in
the town.
Obviously you look for the
maximum similarity with the
customers who already bought
before you send your salesman
and promote the product because
you don't.
Your company doesn't want to
spend money with selling it to
everybody going after
everybody's army In Sync.
Yeah. Yes.
So don't go with the 95% for.
So for example, if your company
is in a very, very desperate
state that you have to acquire
the customer, so even .8
similarity, they will send
somebody to promote the product.
But if there is so much demand
that your customer is your
company is unable to service the
customers unless the customer
has .99 similarity, then you
don't want to even talk to him.
Or you may even want don't want
to talk to anybody because the
customers are anyway walking to
you.
I I don't know this this because
you are trying to solve some
problem.
It is not really.
You are looking at the numbers
for the sake of it.
Let's look at the numerical
data.
So we will see how to handle the
numerical data.
So suppose that we have got data
which is a numerical data.
One example that comes promptly
is suppose we have customer one
and.
You have got 3 customers or
three employees or what?
OK, so there is an income.
So five one person has an income
of let's say 5,00,000.
Another person has 50 lacs and
another person has 10 lacks and
one person has.
Let me put it as 25,00,000.
OK, so now there are four
people.
Each person has got a different
income, so you can solve it in
many ways, right?
So how do you distinguish them
and how to compare the distance?
Because you need to compare the,
you need to make the distance
measurement for some problem.
So let's not worry about the
problem.
So no one way is that you we
simply take it as a numeric and
then compute the distance.
But of course we have to scale
it because the scale of income
is not good or other thing is
that can we call it into a
categorical attributes.
So can we say that the income is
categories?
Income category it's a low
income, high income and middle
income and maybe this also will
put it as a middle income.
So now we converted the income
into 3 distinct categories and
this has become an ordinal
attribute.
So yell.
Hmm is an ordinal attribute and
use that to compute distance.
Or we can use the combine,
convert the data simply into a
binary attributes.
So for example, we are saying
that we think the
differentiators the gadget will
be bought by people who are
likely to have a salary more
than 20,00,000 per year.
So now what we say is that now
let's do with.
So this person is likely to buy
the gadget.
This person is likely to buy the
gadget.
This person will not buy the
gadget.
This person is not so.
Now forget about the income.
We got a binary attribute and
beyond this we can also think in
terms of scaling the scaling
this we have already seen and we
will also see some more methods
of scaling the data.
So scaling the data is simple,
scaling is I I'm going to
convert this the the min, Max
scaling 50 -, 545 I divide
everything by 45 and I'm going
to get the values somewhere in
the zero to 1.
Right.
So so that can be one approach.
Scaling scaling can take
multiple approaches.
We are going to see that.
How are we going to do the
scaling?
So so we we can understand that
there are two ways 2 distinct
ways other than the scaling we
can do.
And the third one is
normalization.
That scaling is we are going to
see.
So so all of this are approaches
for handling the numeric data,
and another concern that we may
have with the numeric data is
that for example, we are
receiving data from 100 sensors.
So this is 100 IT sensors.
And now let us say they are
sending the data after every one
hour.
So we have accumulated huge
data.
I mean, it is possible that for
some problems we may have
million sensors.
So so now the point is that so
they are sending the data of the
form.
So let's say 9 point 379.41.
9.39.
9.38.
So now we can capture the data
as it is, but then you can also
suspect as a data scientist
saying that all the sensors.
Or not equally accurate.
Great.
So it is possible that the
actual data is 9.4, but all of
them are putting it into
different values.
So now you don't ask me, how do
I know that the sensors
accuracy?
So the point is that we when we
get the data, we get the data
from so many sources that we
miss sometimes when we get a
data from research agencies, the
research agency will not share
the method of collecting the
data.
They only say that, OK, we will
sell the data for this price you
are willing to pay.
Take the, otherwise leave it so
that is.
That happens for many times
because they they have their
own.
They have their own uh clauses
of privacy and others so they
cannot tell the source of
information.
So in such cases, so you and
obviously you, you may not trust
the 100% accuracy of the data.
So that it is possible that when
they collect the data, some
possible errors may have topic.
So.
So now what we are saying is
that we will do a smoothing.
So a numeric attributes.
So this is representing 1
popular very popular database.
So many people use this data set
to solve many data science
methods.
Check the many data science
methods so this data set is
available at many public
websites.
So Pima Indians diabetes
database.
So this is indicating.
So this is the this is the
presence or absence of diabetes.
Of disease.
And we are looking at many
attributes and I'm not sure
whether this is the.
I think this is the complete
set, but I'm I'm I I can't
recollect so there may be more
attributes also so please spare
me from that.
So this is representing the
types of attributes that you
that they doctors thought or
important to characterize
whether a person has got the
disease or not.
So, so so this is the this is
what you can see is that many
attributes are numeric but many
of these attributes have got it
different types of ranges.
So number of pregnancies that
person went through can be is a
smaller number, but glucose
level is a bigger number and
then the age is in a different
range by itself.
Blood pressure has its own
range, so.
So for example, if you take some
count of some RBC or something,
it may come out to be much
wider, much different range.
So so you need to think of
numeric attributes with diverse
range and for that region we
need to think of preprocessing
that.
So one web approach we said is
that discretization, so
discretization is to is possibly
can be converted can be based on
some ranges.
So suppose we take the age and
we are going to create these
discrete ranges or we can create
a conceptual labels.
So so this can be the very
simple steps of doing a
discretization.
So all we got is that in the
previous example, we got the
income.
So we decided that anybody
having the income greater than a
greater than five 7,00,000 is a
middle income less than 7,00,000
is low in low income and greater
than 30 greater than 22,00,000.
That's what I said, right?
That's what.
OK, 25, we put it as middle
income.
So greater than 30,00,000 is
high income.
So let's say so very simple.
Then we convert same thing we
can do with the age.
Sir, I have a question here like
so.
Yes, yes, go ahead.
Are we not biasing in terms of
the categorization right?
How are we coming into the
categories like for example zero
to 25 Lake is 1 category.
Maybe it is for this population.
It is low category or Academy
maybe for some.
That is right.
That is right to Mr Party that
actually you can the the
labeling that you take is also
dependent on the problem.
Because for one problem or
certain labels may work well,
but for other problems they may.
For example, if you are willing
to buy a a fancy gadget of very
expensive size, the way you
categorize the income is
different from when the
government has to look at the
people who should be given free
rise. Right?
So.
So The thing is that the purpose
will differentiate the the way
you go about are we In Sync, Mr
Paris?
Yeah, sure.
OK.
So these are the simple steps
whereby we are going to create
the where concept here labels.
It is also possible that we
don't stop with the conceptual
label.
We may create a conceptual
hierarchy, so we have said that,
let us say the income.
So now let me go into income.
At very high level, I divided
into three groups list, saying
that low income, middle income
and high income.
So the middle income, I can say
that the lower middle class and
upper middle class, which you
may have heard many times in
many, many of the financial
contexts saying that upper
middle class is is nowadays
doing this and a lower middle
class is this.
And all this similarly among the
high income groups.
So you can say that ultra high.
And simple high.
So for example, you cannot
compare high income group, for
example somebody you make.
If that person has an income of
1,00,00,000, you may say it is
a high income group, but then
you cannot compare that person
with let's play, say like the
ambanis or Adonis. Right?
So.
So in that case you may want to
create further categories
because that your problem
requires it.
It's not because you are doing
it, because for just for the
sake of sake of it.
So in that case, what you do is
you create a concept hierarchy
and the concept hierarchy is
very common with respect to
things like the distances, so or
or for example, the.
You may say that the the
distance.
So for example, you may say the
intercontinental distances, then
international distances within
the same continent and states
the distance between the States
and distance between the
districts and within the
district you may have a
something lower level at the
loop and then distances between.
So the point is that you create.
You can create a mini
hierarchies and that that may
help your problem.
So it is it again.
I'm leaving it that it you may
do it if it helps with your
problem.
And this discretization level
can take, let's look at this
supervised and unsupervised.
So now, now let me give a very
simple example.
Just to close this so I have got
one category saying that income.
And we kill the person has so
income, let's say in 1000.
So let's say 10,000 and the
person is riding a motorcycle,
then 20,000 the person is
writing a car 30,000 his
motorcycle, 40,000 is
motorcycle, 50,000 is car, then
55,000 is a motorcycle.
Then 60,000 is writing a car, so
now is it helping you to do a
discretization or not?
No.
Somebody give an answer?
No.
No. Why?
No.
Because you can see that the
people below this income tending
You.
to buy go by motorcycle and
above this income or tending to
go by car.
You can always find the
exceptions that that is.
In fact, I put it deliberately
to exceptions because you you
should recognize that when you
get the data, you cannot simply
assume that the data is going to
give work like a Bible for you,
because it is possible that this
because one thing is see.
First thing is that you assume
that income is going to impact
whether the person will what
type of vehicle the person will
have.
OK, that is the assumption.
So now let us say that
assumption still you hold it,
but then it is possible that
this person with 20K income has
got a father with who is very
rich and this person with 55K
income has got lot of
responsibilities.
So it is quite possible that you
there are exceptions, but in
spite of that there is a.
This is helping you to give a
supervised discretization.
Are we?
Are we In Sync?
Yeah, the data is is a low
value, so it was hard to you
know categories.
No, but then, OK, I'll.
I'll put some more value just to
make you comfortable.
OK, one more value.
So you can make out that yes,
there is a tendency below 45 K
people tend to have a motorcycle
and they above 45 K people tend
to have car, right?
Yes.
So so now that is become a
supervised discretization.
So the numbers are not telling,
but you have another class label
that you are saying that OK, the
way that the type of vehicle
that person drives is a you are
treating that as a class label
and then that is giving you a
supervision with respect to how
to discretize the ink.
Alright.
This is this is supervised and
you can also have unsupervised
which is saying that do not
depend on any other class label,
only look at the data and do the
discretization so that that is
the two approaches to do the
discretization and these are
these are independent and top
down and bottom up are also
independent.
So so you can do in all the
cases all the types, so top down
Can I have again?
is saying that you first break
up into.
I have one one example of
supervised unsupervised.
Unsupervised is don't use the
vehicle, so you do the
discretization.
OK.
OK, then top down is that you
divide it first the people into
low income people and high
income people.
And then within the low income
people, you started saying that
somebody is below poverty line
and somebody is having
marginally low income and the
high income people you divided
them into middle class and upper
class.
So that is a top down
discretization you are going
from the top and you are
splitting and then bottom up.
You are seeing that you are
seeing there are these things
are very close, so I put them
into single group and these and
so you start looking at things
which you are going to merge
because those neighborhood
intervals you think that there
cannot be differentiation there.
So in that case, what you are
doing is bottom up.
Your first merging some of the
intervals and then after that
you have a reduced number.
So previously we had eight
values, now we had only six
values and you let's look at how
to discretize this.
So this is bottom of approach.
So here do we give a range or we
will give one number Sir.
No, the how we use it is
different thing because once you
do it discretization, you may
decide to go with the labels.
So like the way middle income
and low income or or you may
still keep that as a variable
because nothing stops you from
defining a new variable saying
that a person's income is in the
range of 40 to 60 K you create a
new variable like that and you
put Y.
If that person has income in
that range.
Otherwise, no, because you
converted in a way effectively
into a categorical or nominal
type of feel.
So it depends or or.
OK.
Sometime we may say that, OK, we
are all putting them together
into a single number.
So that is that really your
problem demands it?
Maybe you you may convert that
40 and 50 and replace it by 45,
but that that you will do it if
you think that that problem
really demands it.
But then in that case, that may
become as well a categorical
because you combine many of them
and put it as an average, uh.
Unless you know the range you,
you're virtually treating the
number like a categorical.
No.
Let us look at the methods of
binning.
So what we are saying is that we
said that this is a binning is
for the purpose of smoothing.
So what we do is that we divide
them into groups or and then and
then of course the smoothing and
it can also help in
discretization.
So let me put it's not always
for it can serve both the
purposes, both it can smoothing
and discretization.
So now let's see.
Suppose that there is a width
that we compute.
So and then of course, this is
once you use this then it is
sensitive to outlier because in
this case suppose that we got
1020304050556070.
So if we take these numbers and
we create 2 bins, so one is
below 45 and other is above 45
then that is one thing.
But now suppose that I want to
divide this into three bins
based on equal range, so 70 -,
10 is 60, so I make 10 to 31,
then 31 to 50 is another 151 to
70 is another one.
So in that case you have to be
watchful because there may be
outliers.
Suppose that somehow through
through some noisy noise in the
process, you put this as a 7000
which is which is not a, which
is actually an outlier which is
not within the types of the
analysis that you are
performing.
So now it is impacting the
range.
So we have to be watchful of
that.
So we convert the data into
equal with equal width ranges,
equal width ranges and each
interval size is maximum to
minimum divided by the number of
bins that we want to have or the
number of ranges that we want to
have.
We can also go for an equal
depth binning.
So what we do is that we have
suppose 9 items and we need to
put them into three bins.
So we are going to put 333 equal
number into this.
So in that process, the range of
the bins may be different.
So now let us look at this
example.
Suppose we have got this data
and then we want to do in 2-3
discrete categories using the
binning.
So first thing what we have to
do is that we have to sort the
data.
OK, after sorting the data then
we are going to get the range so
so the first thing is that we
have sorted this so we have got
to 53 to 81 after sorting it and
now what we are saying is that
first method is equal with equal
width is that 81 -?
53 is 2828 by three is 9.33.
So what we are saying is that
the first one is 53 to 62,
second one is 62 to 72, then the
third one is 72 to 81.
So that is the way we are
creating the range and then we
are saying that then we are
putting this into into equal
width categories.
So we created the the range for
each bin.
And we have put we have put the
items that belong to this.
So in this case we got three
items in bin one and we got a
lot of 11 items in bin two and
we got 10 items in bin three.
But we can also go for equal
depth.
So we have 24 items.
So why not divide them into
three groups?
So now we are saying that each
one group has eight and so we
are creating 3 equal sized bins.
So the range of this bin is 14.
The range of this bin is 5 range
of this bin is 6.
Right.
Uh, so, can you read explain
this that how you divided and
Yeah. Yes.
because uh, for all range are
coming different different.
Yes, yes, yes, that is what now
two methods we have learned only
two methods.
One is equal size or one we call
it as equal frequency and then
the other one we are calling it
as equal with OK equal width and
equal depth.
So equal width is saying that
the range is equal and then
equal depth is saying that the
number of elements in each bin
is equal.
Miss Ruby, are we in Singh?
Said.
Uh, first, you are telling that
equal equal. Ohh.
No, no, just don't, Mr.
We don't talk as if I have done
some something wrong.
I'm saying this and I'm saying
that no, I'm not saying that.
No, no.
In fact, I'm telling whatever
the authors and whatever the
other data scientists say,
please tell me what is the what
is that you did not understand?
I said I am.
I'm not able to understand that
all three the difference between
all three.
No, no, no, no, Mr B, we try.
We looked at only two methods,
not 3 methods, 2 methods.
One is equal width and the other
is equal frequency or equal size
Uh, so we have not done.
by size.
We are taking number of elements
in the bin should be but
Missouri are we In Sync?
We have not understood the
weights of answer.
No.
The weight of 1.
OK.
Just let Mr Srinivas let us
wait.
Missouri.
Are we In Sync or are we?
Am I missing something?
Uh, no, I want to understand
both, Sir.
Once more equal wealth than we
call frequency, you can.
OK, OK.
I'm I'm going to that slide.
OK. This slide.
OK, so one is equal width and
other is equal depth equal depth
is same as equal frequency.
Missouri.
Arvin.
Sync there because equal depth
and equal frequency is same.
OK, so we want same number of
elements in each bin.
OK, OK.
OK, so that is the intention.
OK.
We want three bins, but then how
to divide?
We have two methods in both the
methods we are getting 3 bins.
But when we use the width to be
the same, the width of the bin
should be same.
That is the maximum minus
minimum the value of the element
of the maximum minus minimum has
to be same then we are getting
different sized bins.
But when we go for equal
frequency of the bins then we
are getting equal different
widths.
It's.
Yeah, it will deplete clear.
The different bin is clear but
equal width width is not getting
Because see the equal width we
are computing because we got the
cleared.
maximum is 81 and minimum is 53.
We said that each each has to
get an approximately 9 size 9.
So first bin, we created 53 to
62, then second 163 to 72 third
172.
Is that a problem the width?
Ah yes, I yes, I I guess we got.
Umm.
So basically 9 items should be
there in one bin as per the
equal bit methodology, right?
No, no, no, not 9.
The range of the maximum range
of the items should be 9 little
Like the maximum, right?
Right, exactly.
bit, yeah yeah.
Exactly that. What?
Serve with that like on bintu,
shouldn't the range be like 62
to 71 rather than 72?
No, because there is no item.
I think with the value so 62 to
71.
Yeah, that is correct.
That is correct, because 72 is
going into the other side.
That is, yes, Sir.
It is actually saying that less
than 72 that is what that is
Yeah.
what it is meant to be.
So it is excluding 72, yeah,
excluding 72, yeah.
OK, got it.
OK.
So bracket is the means we are
excluding that value.
Yes, yes, yes.
OK, OK.
What it's about?
Yeah.
Now I get it that in the equal
depth we are taking that equal
equal number of elements count
and here we are taking the range
of 9.33.
OK.
Wow.
That is, that's yes, Mr
Srinivas, is it clear now to
Almost nine, yeah.
It's.
you?
OK.
OK, fine.
Alright so.
Yeah.
That this right is that this
slide is reduced this.
Yes, Sir.
Excuse me, Sir, that I had a
question.
Yes, Mr cabin.
OK, you have a question.
Go ahead.
So sorry if this was explained
earlier, but why are we taking
like 3-3 bins?
So what was the purpose for
three bins 1?
No, no, no, no.
That three is because of the
domain requirement.
So we cannot say if whenever you
can always think in terms of why
Yet.
But.
three and why, why not five in?
Yeah, that is because, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, right,
Right.
So it will be given right what
we want to do, like how many
beans we want.
OK, OK, Sir.
right.
Thank you.
And sort of one question here.
In the second method that we saw
wherein we were distributing the
equal number of items in each
bin, right.
Right, right.
So there I noticed that the data
set is in the sorted order like.
Right, right.
Is it intentional that we are
sorting it and then dividing the
No, we have to support it
because if we want to put it
equal number of?
into bins, we have to sort it
first, right?
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
80 ohh so one question.
The impact of outliers are we
saying that?
Yes.
Are we saying that in the width
method it will be spread across
all bins but in depth only once?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, we that
is true in in case of a equal
OK.
Thank you.
depth of the outlier impact is
not there but equal width.
The outlier is going to
significantly distort a A equal
bit, binning Mr Santosh that is
the question, right? Yes.
Right, right.
So but in in the in the depth,
the outlier impact will be
Yes.
there, but maybe we limited to
one or two bins.
One bin only?
Yeah, because we you want to
apply some process on that bin
by smoothing or averaging then
it will be impacting.
But otherwise the binning itself
is not so much impact.
Right.
Thank you, Sir.
Sir.
But which one is the ideal one?
That if possible.
No.
Ohh no, there is nothing like a
ideal so it it really depends on
Nothing I said.
OK, OK. Yeah.
the the problem that we want to
solve.
Dataset.
Would you be able to relative?
Would you be able to help us and
understand in which scenario we
should be using which binning
methodology here like where it
would be fitting more?
Uh, see?
It is like this.
So sometimes you do the binning
only for the purpose of
smoothing.
So for example, you have got a
data where you you see that the
Umm.
sensors may be sending the data
which is somewhat distorted
because of the because of the
environment or some factors by
which it's unable to make a
correct measurement.
So in such case what you do is
that you are really putting them
into some ranges and then
smoothing them into the same
values.
So so if the domain demands it,
then it is different, but
otherwise you cannot say really
because there are million or
billion problems.
So you cannot really list that
out if you bring in a problem, I
may be able to help you.
I am though I I I don't want to
guarantee, but I need help.
OK.
So if you put it in a canvas
with a specific problem, then we
Sure.
mean we may be able to help.
OK, so it depends on problem.
Probably the data scientists you
have to analyze which one you
Yeah, absolutely, that's.
feel is better in this
particular situation.
That is correct, right?
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
Still another way of doing a
discretization is with the help
of histograms.
So histograms are very common
things.
All of us have used it in many
contexts, so all we are saying
is that we plot histogram and so
histogram is effectively acting
like a bin that though
histograms, we use them in
different terminology which is
bucket.
So so we are looking at the
histograms and the histogram is
telling us the thing pretty much
like the bin.
So when we take an equal width,
this is what we are getting when
it is equal frequency, we are
getting this type of ranges and
we can use the same like the
binning analysis.
We can use this in order to
proceed further.
But they can be.
We can also go for a more
sophisticated methods, so a more
sophisticated methods.
So we are going to look at the
specific algorithms.
So this picture I'm I have
directly taken from the both the
authors have given similar
pictures so this one I think I
had taken from the T4 they hands
slide so all we are saying is
that we will talk about K means
much later after mid semester
the algorithm but then we need
to understand that when we have
the data like this.
Suppose this is the data we are
talking about.
And we need to do the binning or
we need to do a discretization.
So luckily for us, we got a data
which looks clearly meant for
discretization.
So if we go for equal width
method so this is what we will
end up with.
Then we go for equal depth
method.
We go for, we end up with this
because both of them have or are
simple mathematical approaches
which which are not trying to
look at the data by itself.
But then if we do a clustering,
clustering is a machine learning
approach of distinguishing the
elements of data that we got.
Then we are expected to get
better results.
So now, now you may realize
something that the why the data
science process is iterative.
So even for doing the
preprocessing, sometimes you
need to use the data science
algorithms.
The essentially, when we say in
the data science process, when
we looked at in the first class,
we said that, OK, we will do the
data processing, then we are
going to apply some algorithms
and then we are going to get the
results.
But the preprocessing itself can
be a tricky process that may
involve use of.
Several data science techniques,
including several algorithms.
OK, so that is the message.
OK, so now let us look at that
transformation.
Uh, OK, so maybe we should take
a small break or or there is
So so.
some question coming up.
Yeah.
So I had one question on this
last slide.
Hmm. Yes.
I I was trying to understand the
what are we trying to visualize
in the width versus the depth
related graph that we had?
How the data is being
differently here?
What?
What's the relevance of binning
in each of that?
Or just one minute.
Just one minute.
Uh, we need to.
OK.
So no, no, all I'm saying is
that you have got several data
objects which have been plotted.
So there can be many, many times
you may end up getting millions
Mm-hmm.
of records.
So first thing you may want to
do is to do some visualization.
OK.
So in this case this is how it
looked like, because in this
case you are actually lucky
because the data is showing up.
Clearly a trend whereby you can
do it, you can do a a separation
into multiple groups, but in
that case you can see that if
Hmm.
you use binning is becoming a
dumb method for doing it.
So you need a smarter method,
are you?
Mm-hmm.
Are we In Sync?
Yes.
So so how is so?
How is this a statement you know
holding through that K means
clustering leads to better
results.
How are we saying it?
By looking at the graph here.
Known by because you you are
clearly see that none of the
groups of the items have been
disturbed because you can see
that in second diagram the blue
group is disturbed and it is put
into different bins.
Similarly, Red Group items got
distinguished and put into two
distinct bins, which you don't
want, right?
Because in this case none of
these items got disturbed, so
Oh.
Ohh.
OK, OK OK, OK.
all of them which belong which
seem to be similar or staying in
a similar group.
OK.
OK, OK, I got it now.
I was not reading it correctly,
so zero to six is one of the bin
6 to 10 is another and 10 to 16
is another.
Then and yeah, there's no.
Uh, yeah, this similar items are
falling into two different
buckets.
Also, two different bills makes
sense, Sir.
Nightmares.
OK, OK.
Sorry that you know, I could not
understand.
All right.
Yeah.
OK, so now what we do is that we
look at variable transformation
and maybe maybe a break is
better.
Yes, Sir.
Yes.
Yes, Sir. Yes.
Let us take a 5 minute break.
Yes.
So I see some that this is slide
#4, right?
Yeah, taking.
Ohh, this like Big 5 you're
talking about a slide deck 5R4.
Is for yeah.
We are in slide deck.
Yeah, no.
OK.
But here also I see the both the
same.
We need this is like the I I do
not know what is the question
See here also.
you are asking.
Yeah, here that discretization
techniques.
Was that in the slide?
Both are in the both are in the
same same slides are.
No, no what?
No, no, no, no.
Slide four and five are same.
What I I do not know this is
this is something it is there.
You are seeing that this slide
is present in two decks.
Is that what you're saying?
Define this slide is there in 4
the modules.
It's so in last class we talked
about it.
That is what you are saying.
We did not talk about it in the
last class.
The slide may be present, but we
did not talk right.
What do you present in the last
class?
Yeah. Yes.
So do you remember that we
talked about this?
No, no, Sir.
He he's saying that.
Are you the trying to slide #4?
I think you're doing the slide
#5 right, which is not yet
uploaded to Carlos.
Yeah, right, right. Yes.
Why do you create more confusion
than that we already have?
OK.
So we can let's take break.
Hello Sir, I had a question.
Can I ask though?
OK, we can get restarted.
Right.
Hello Sir, I had a question
regarding quiz.
Can I ask it now or should I
wait for the end of the class?
Yeah.
Tell me.
Tell me what is the question?
Yeah.
Ohh so Sarah, like what would be
the kind of questions that we'll
be expecting like they will be
MCQ or OK and in so like in
Yes, yes, that is correct.
That is correct, MCQS yes.
first few lectures I think a
couple of LECTURES we it it was
mostly theoretical, right.
So the questions that we'll be
getting for quiz, they would be
more like a computational
wearing will be you know
computing something on the data
or would they be theoretical
because you know, Sir, we have
not seen we we are not very sure
how to prepare for the quiz and
this would be the ideas would be
No, no, see.
the first quiz that you'll be
attempting.
No, no, just one minute.
So that yes, yes, yes.
Just one minute, Miss Pooja
misspeak.
Puja don't prepare for the quiz.
So what do you do is that you
learn the subject, so you just
go through the contents,
textbooks, lectures, videos and
slides, everything, learn it,
but don't prepare for the quiz.
Is that fine?
And she has it.
So can we have a list of topics
that we can expect and that was
OK. Thank.
like what is the heading?
So, so so the idea is that the
quizzes to ensure that you are
doing a continuous learning and
not waiting for the exams to
come.
Does that help?
So just like a comprehensive
view of like what topics will be
covered in the quiz.
See, the point is that the quiz
has only one purpose.
That is, to ensure that you are
constantly learning, so that is
saying that that is saying that
as the things go, you review
them and you learn them, you
explore them, don't wait for the
exam.
So nothing more.
So don't say that exam at the
syllabus this this topics and
all that.
So obviously, obviously I we
hope it helps.
Said.
Yeah.
So are we supposed to do some
computational Sir and?
Yes, Mr KAVIN NILAN, slide deck
15 and slide #59 ID, ID 4, PPTX.
And what is there set?
OK, OK.
I think that is fine because in
what we did is that you are
possibly looking at slide deck
uploaded by the faculty of other
others.
Because when I sent the slide
deck for ID S4, we obviously
expected to cover more, but we
didn't cover that far.
So we had to put it into slide
deck file.
So.
So you look at your part of the
Section 1 and you look at what I
upload in a Section 1.
So you will have lesser
confusion.
Sir, regarding the quizzes, you
know the the anxiety is also
coming because we are
overwhelmed with four core
subject and all are taking so
much of our time.
And so, you know, the preparing
for the quizzes is is not the
top of the mine now you know,
you know it will help that.
Yes, we do continuous learning
and then attempt the quiz.
But the scenario is not that
because of the overwhelming
content that we all are
processing in such a short time
so.
No, but then I see.
See what is the what is, what is
going to happen.
Again, they examinations will
also be again one after the
other, is it not so?
So when the mid semester
examinations, you may have heard
the schedule that they will
happen at the same time for all
four.
It is not like ID S examination
will happen in January and
another subject in February.
All of them will happen in the
over the weekend.
So.
So I'm not saying it's it's a
trivial task, but it it has an.
It's really we don't have any
escape clause there.
Yeah.
And that is why we are
prioritizing the exam and only
the content.
What is important?
So it would have.
Not I don't worry about that.
No, once you if you are in, if
you are In Sync with this
subject, I know I think you will
do that should not be.
OK.
So we will proceed further.
So we can do the transformation
of the data when it is a
numerical data, we can think of
doing some transformations.
So what are those
transformations like?
Why do we do the transformation?
The transformations can be
mathematical.
So for example, we take the data
and then we raise it to the
power or we take a logarithm of
that we take exponent of that we
do a query and we do many many
things that we can possibly do.
So the intent of doing that is
very often to do the
transformation that can lead to
some purpose.
So so there are many algorithms.
I hope we have it somewhere.
The algorithms where the data
transformation helps to solve
and at this point we will not go
into those algorithms, but then
the data transformation is a
requirement for for effectively
working with those algorithms.
So we will, we will face them as
they come.
So you may perform the
transformation.
So this is not saying that
always you have to do that
transformation and then there is
another reason why you perform
transformation.
Sometimes when you perform these
operations, when you perform
these operations, the data will
have a better distribution.
That is mathematically more
tractable than taking the normal
values, so that can be the other
reason.
OK.
And and we look at the
normalization.
So we already looked at one
method of normalization.
So when we talk about the
normalization, we want to reduce
them into certain groups or
certain categories so that it is
easy to manage.
So so it can be so we can look
at that.
So the one of the ways we do it
is through the scaling.
So the scaling is required
because when the features some
features with bigger magnitude
dominate over the features with
the smaller magnitude.
If we do not do it, OK.
And so it's a good idea that we
scale them to a similar scale
and we also go for go for the
when we use the, when we use the
algorithms like gradient
descent, if many of you may not
be knowing few people maybe
knowing in that case they may
understand it.
But for those who don't
understand, this is one more
algorithm which you are going to
study as part of the machine
learning.
So this is to this is for
training a neural network.
So in such cases, when you have
done this scaling, that works
better.
And similarly support vector
machine that also we may not be
able to cover.
So that is an algorithm that is
that is helpful in doing a
supervised machine learning.
So we had already looked at this
example data set so we can see
that each one of these
attributes has different ranges,
so scaling is going to give the
new importance to all
attributes.
And here is a list of algorithms
that require the scaling to be
Background.
done to work efficiently.
I don't think tomato cup.
A lot of umm GAWARI.
Alright, so maybe I'm I'm seeing
some noise, so let me mute
people for the time being.
OK, so now now let's look at
what are the methods for
normalizing the numerical data.
So we can use min, Max
normalization or jet score
normalization or normalization
by decimal scaling.
So decimal scaling is very
simple.
Suppose that we have people with
the income of.
So let me take again the income
examples.
So represent them as 1.5 two and
three, because you just include
multiplied by 10 to the power of
minus six, and then this is
becoming a decimal scaling
because you are rising, you are
using a 10 to the power so it is
a decimal scaling.
So what you get will be 1.523,
so that can be one approach
which is the last one.
And let us look at the other
approaches, other approaches.
First one we look at is min Max
scaling.
So in Min Max scaling what we
are doing is that we are trying
to put they really attribute in
the range of 0 to one.
So suppose that we got some data
that is X, so we will use the
this app formula.
So that it is going into the new
minimum.
So.
So in this case we have not used
because it is 0 new minimum is
0.
So and then the new range is 1
and new minimum is 0.
So we need to did not use but
sometimes you may want to put
the values in the range of five
to 10.
So in that case you may have to
do this for me.
So let's look at the examples.
So what we are saying is that we
have the income in the range of
12,000 to 98,000.
So we want to put it into zero
to 1 range and so we want to get
the value for 73,600.
So the way to convert it is that
when we convert we are getting a
value of .716.
I hope it is clear.
Then let us look at The Jets
code normalization jets score
normalization is that you get
the data big the mean.
And compute the standard
deviation and use The Jets
score.
Is it dual to this for the data?
So for every X we are
subtracting the mean and
dividing it by the Sigma.
So this way so previously we had
a normal distribution which was
one by two by Sigma and then E
to the power of minus X minus MU
divided by two Sigma squared.
This is becoming much simpler,
right?
This is becoming much simpler.
So what we are saying is that X
minus MU by Sigma this.
So this is becoming jet.
So E to the power of minus Z
square.
That is what we are going to
get.
I hope that is the that is the
formula right?
So this can be one approach.
For example, now we have the
same income.
So, so now we also know that the
standard deviation is 16 and
mean is 54.
So we are going to get the jet
score using this approach.
So this will be the jet score.
And we can do the decimal
normalization, which is simple
divide X by 10 to the power of
some scaling that you want to do
whatever you consider is
reasonable.
So you can look at the examples
of decimal scaling.
So CGPA V change from 2 to .2
and the bonus we change it into
a normalized bonus.
And then similarly, we can have
the normalization based on
various scalings and then we
will look at the another aspect
which is that how do we work
with categorical data when
particularly when we are writing
the programs or when we are
working with the the data for
sit and algorithms.
So we may want to represent that
by using an encoding, so the
encoding is.
There are two broad categories
of encoding that people work
with, so one is 1 hot encoding,
1 hot encoding is saying that we
are converting the categorical
attribute.
For example, we have categorical
attributes.
Uh, gender.
And there is a male female.
So we are converting it into a
vector of size 2, so if it is
mail, the values will be one and
then zero.
Then it is female.
This is zero and one.
So so this can be the in
approach.
So here The thing is that it is
simply converting it into a
numerical value and that may be
used binary attribute for some
purpose, but then it is
increasing the feature space
because it is adding new
attributes and and then it is a.
It is a in that sense.
It has an overhead, so if we
look at suppose that there is a
service quality that we are
talking about, there are five
attributes 5 possible values.
So we replaced it with the five
five attributes.
Each one can be represented by 1
bit, but now we are dealing with
five attributes.
So if we think that this is
going to help us in some way, we
can, we may do it.
There is really the one hot
encoding is a popular technique,
particularly people use it in
language processing because each
word they represent it.
But then they realized that that
the better technique will be you
create a proper embeddings which
are of much lower density.
Converting it into numbers, the
word has to be converted into
number.
They they are choosing a
different type of vector rather
than one hot, but then this one
hot as an output is always a
feasible.
For example, you are trying to
get the some data and dividing
it into and then predicting a
particular class.
Suppose that you want to predict
one among the five classes.
Suppose that you have been given
some data and then some.
Let's say some words set of
words and you need to predict
whether they are noun or verb or
adjective or adverb.
So so now now the point is that
so you can represent that using
one hot vectors.
So each one of them is going to
get a different bit set, so that
is going to help in solving the
output problem.
But sometimes we may do it for
the input also.
So.
So in that case we are creating
the additional attributes and
are setting the values.
And another approach, another
one that we frequently use is
the label encoding.
So label encoding is a more
reasonable thing, so here we are
not adding any extract tribute.
All we are saying is that
suppose there are colors.
Color can be green, blue, red.
So we are representing them 123
without meaning anything.
So so there is only one
variable, but then it uses some
values rather than using the
text or the OR the nominal
values.
OK.
So are we.
I hope this is a very simple
concept.
I hope people are In Sync.
OK, so now what we do is that
let us take another example for
proximity and possibly see
whether we are able to solve it.
So this is the problem
description.
So there are four data objects
again.
So we had already done it once
with the four data objects, but
three attributes.
So now let us do it with a
slightly different bigger
problem where four data objects
and four attributes.
So.
So what we know is that this is
this is a numeric, right?
And these two are nominal.
And this is ordinal.
So how do we do that?
First, we need to do the
transformation of the data.
So what we are doing is we are
doing a min Max transformation
for a numbers for the numeric
data into the range of 0 to one.
So what we are doing is that we
are doing the we are taking.
So 70,000 is becoming.
70,000 -, 50,000.
Divided by 80,000 -, 50,000.
Multiplied by.
Ohh this is zero to 1 range and
then multiplied by 1 + 0 so
these things don't matter.
So what we are saying is that it
is becoming too by three, right?
So this is .67.
Similarly, this one is 0.
This one is 1 and this one is .3
and so now what we do is that we
directly compute the distances
and then we have to divide this
by 4 because no the there are
four attributes.
So we may want to put divide by
4 in order to get the distance
value between 0 to one, but this
is sufficient for us to find
what is The Who are the most
similar people and who are the
most dissimilar.
I hope we are In Sync.
Uh, anyone be having any further
questions?
Just give me.
Give me one minute.
I hope uh, let me enable the MIC
for all of you.
Browser the last question I'm
not able to understand.
Yeah this this.
OK, OK.
This light, right? Yes.
Yes.
Yeah, can.
Can you please explain this
letter?
No, no.
What?
What is that?
Maybe this is actually the same
problem we are doing second time
because we have done one problem
with a simpler data.
Like.
Let we just enhance the data to
compute this.
So maybe maybe you can help me
understand where is the what is
the real difficulty.
Now, how did we?
So.
How did we arrive at 0.69 for
RAM income?
Yes, yes.
0.67 for ram.
OK, this is using the min, Max,
normalization, min, Max
normalization.
Let me go to the slide where we
did the min Max normalization
formula.
So this is the formula that we
want to use.
So whatever is the value is
there.
We subtract from that the
minimum and then scale it by
maximum to minimum.
That is the entire range, and if
the new Max minus new mean if
the if the range is something we
want to put it in range of five
to 10 or 6 to 10 that is
different.
But our intention is 0 to one.
So in this case, we don't need
to do anything because 1 -, 0 is
1, so multiplying by 1 doesn't
make a difference, and new mini
0.
So that also doesn't make a
difference.
So straight away this is the
approach.
So the same approach we have
used to compute the this value
are we In Sync now or are there
some still Singh?
Uh.
The income is clear, right?
So can you.
So can you show that slide, Sir?
Where you did.
No, no, just one minute.
Just one minute, Missouri.
Mr Saurabh is the income
calculation clear we are
Yes, that is clear.
getting.
You have used the new Min Max
formula.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is clear.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, I understood this.
So that is clear.
OK.
OK, fine.
Now Miss Ruby, can you ask the
question please?
Uh, yeah.
Just I want to see that Min, Max
one once please.
OK, Min, Max formula you want to
see again.
OK, OK.
Yeah, and.
OK.
Yeah, yeah, fine.
Fine.
I'm going there.
Yeah.
So this is the formula, yes.
OK.
Alright.
So what values we are taking for
professions?
Profession.
We are taking it as a nominal
attribute, so we are looking at
how many matches are there,
profession and also language.
We are taking them as nominal
attributes, so there are two
nominal attributes and we are
seeing how many of them are
matched and how many are
mismatched.
So when we look at the RAM and
Kishan, the profession is
matched, but the language did
not match, so their distance
will come as .5.
.5, which is a because the we
are we are not showing the
entire metrics.
So in case of RAM and fission,
uh, the value is coming at zero
for profession Dr to doctor and
mother tongue is different.
So it is coming as one so that
when we scale it will it will
come out as a different formula
but we are straight away putting
each one for profession we are
putting in the distance at zero
and for language we are putting
the distance as one.
But when we go for RAM and
BALRAM, the profession also has
a distance of 1 and the language
also got a distance of 1.
Ohh but also this D ramble RAM
which is there.
Phone translate.
Yes.
Yes, go ahead.
OK, so D ramble.
Ram is there, there is 0.67 + 1
+ 1 + 2 -, 1 this calculation
I'm not getting ram, ram.
OK, OK.
But sorry.
Yeah, yeah, sure, sure, sure.
Fine. Fine.
Yeah.
OK, so how am I doing it?
It is very simple so I am doing
a first thing is that I am using
OK OK maybe some some some
explanation I wrote to you.
OK, I'm using Manhattan
distance.
Which is combine all the
distance.
Simply add them up, because
sometimes you may go for an
equally Euclidean approach for
combining the distances.
We I'm going for Manhattan
distance, so I'm adding up all
the distances, so income
distance is .67 -, 0 so it is
.67.
I hope that is clear.
The profession Dr to data
scientist distance is one
language.
They are different, so distance
is 1 the native place.
This is ordinal.
So the distance is 2 -, 1, /, 4,
-, 1 which is the maximum
values, right?
So this is.
Does that help?
Yes, I understood.
Thank you, Rosa.
OK, OK.
Yeah.
OK. So.
So, Sir, how this 4 -?
One came like 2 -, 1 like BALRAM
and Ram.
It is 2, -, 1, but the phone.
Yeah.
Yeah, just just.
OK.
OK, 4 -, 1 is the Mac because
this is an ordinal attribute
ordinal attribute.
Actually we we in the past what
we did is we converted them into
the values which by converting
into Jed score.
So but when we use the jet
score, this is now, let me let
me use the jet score.
Then you will get the same
values but jet score is.
Suppose this is 1.
This is 2.
This is 3.
This is 4.
OK, so in that case, how do we
compute the jet score jet score
OK.
we compute by rank minus 1
divided by the maximum value
minus one.
So.
So what is this for this one?
It will be 0 this one it will be
.33 because four is the maximum
value.
So we have to use the 4 -, 1 to
scale.
So this will be .67.
This will be one.
So now using them we get the
same distance values, so you can
see that the distance values are
coming from that same formula,
but then expression is slightly
different, but it is the same
for.
Instead of one question and
maybe maybe little stupid
Yes.
question, but I still want to
ask and if you go back to the
slide, Sir.
So in the language, for example,
the mother tongue, right?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
So I mean Ms, we are saying that
the distance is 11 and it's
fine.
But consider scenario where and
Hindi and Butch Puri right.
There is a significant overlap
and if you want in the distance
OK.
is not truly 11.
So what do we do in such cases?
He absolutely, Mr Santosh,
absolutely right.
I'm.
I'm glad that you asked the
question and this is a very
intelligent question.
Actually not stupid question and
and then the point is that the
Thank you.
data scientist can do only so
much and now now the the call
whether to include a scaling
there or merging there is really
up to you.
So if you want to merge saying
that Hindi and Bajuri, you will
give the same and you put them
as distance at 0.
So nothing stops.
Mr Amit, were you trying to ask
something?
I can see your mic showing up.
Mr Amit choudhary.
OK.
Maybe maybe that was just a
disturbance.
Loser.
So Mr Santosh, you're fine,
right?
Yes.
Yes, thank you.
OK, OK, alright.
So here.
How?
Why did we?
Did we define this as a ordinal
attribute and not others like
the you only defined one as a.
OK.
Just so that so that we can use
those formula, Mr Romik really,
really.
If you say metropolitan and
cosmopolitan are same, no I I
metropolitan and suburban are
same no it is possible there
same no I don't want to get into
that ordinal so that it helps us
to use that formula.
Nothing.
So we are saying rural art.
So is there any?
Is there any logics or which
attribute should be defined as a
No, but look at this new.
ordinal versus?
No, no, no, no.
Look at this native place.
So does it not look like an
ordinal to you?
Hmm.
I'm OK maybe that helps me.
Mr Do you think that?
So if we can talk about same
thing for the mother tongue
also, right, that could also be
the order our profession.
Umm how?
How the how are you going to
create an ordinal variable out
of the mother tongue?
How do you create that?
Because you need to give me a
ranking, right?
OK.
So that is right.
So if you think that there is
some the distance between the
languages like Mr Santosh has
said, so the last two languages
are a lot of overlap.
So I want to convert them into
the same language.
That is fine.
Nothing stops.
Alright, OK, I hope I hope yes.
Said one more question.
I said.
I said what is from your
perspective?
What exactly the ordinal is
you're referring to?
Can you get?
No ordinary is when there is a
ranking.
Like, suppose you have a.
You have a grade ABCD so that is
ordinal.
So similarly, your company has a
designation, assistant manager,
manager, senior manager, general
manager.
So they are audience.
OK.
Mr Dish RATHNA, is that true?
So kind of the primary kind of
thing you are referring to,
right, Sir, in in a database
normal database.
No language ordinal is difficult
to define.
No, I I do not know your
question.
I do not understand your
question.
Are you looking for some
knowledge or do you want to help
OK.
So no, I just wanted to refer
what exactly ordinal you are
me with something?
referring to, Sir.
What email?
So that. Yes, Sir.
Yes, Sir. Please.
Is it understood now or it is
not understood?
So what I understood is like if
you want to I you uniquely
identify any row in a in a
system so that row we can that
column.
Basically, we can consider it as
ordinal wherein it is a kind of
ranking or some designation
that.
Yes, yes.
So the importance is the ranking
if the ranking is present, you
can call it as ordinance, right?
OK, OK, Sir.
It.
Thank you, Sir.
Yes.
Come here.
Considering the native place
this order first.
Are you asking me something,
miss NANDINI?
It's I mean not audible.
No, you're not audible.
You have to be louder.
OK.
No, I'm asking like we are
considering native places out in
a lateral glute in this example,
right, like.
Yes.
So how come?
So you you don't like that
example, considering the native
place as ordinal?
No, no, no.
Make it doesn't, it does not
define any rank or any category
right?
Like it is just.
No.
Is it not?
See.
See the point is the point I
wanted to make is like this.
It is really I'm talking about
the size of the place and now
the village is a small place.
Small town is a little bigger
place.
Suburban is a even bigger place.
Metropolitan is even bigger and
and I'm happy that because this
example I have been, I have my
may have used it with already
some 6 or 8 or 10 batches.
So I'm happy that you asked, so
I have no problem because I
thought that sometimes you may
say that when you are talking
about a culture of the people.
So you may think that a village
person is closer to a person
Thank you.
with a small town rather than to
a big city or so.
But then so.
But then, if you think that
doesn't work, yeah, I'm.
I'm open to listening to you.
No, Sir.
Got it. Yeah.
No, but then I appreciate the
point that I think you are the
first one, possibly this example
we have been using for we may
have used it already with 10,000
people.
But you have asked it.
That's good.
Said I I have a question about
the the binary translation that
the slide very we're talking.
I did not understand the
significance of that.
Binary is what binary is.
Just saying that into two
categories, putting it into two
categories, right?
Like the way we can have three
categories, we can have two
categories that becomes binary,
right?
No, no, no, no, no.
There was one slide where we
were converting characters into
the bit representation.
Ohh wookie OK all we are saying
is that we are putting it into
putting it into 0001.
So that can be useful in many
times in the programming when
you represent that way, and that
may also be more efficient with
respect to.
Sometimes it is more efficient,
but sometimes it can cause.
You may make you because you are
creating many attributes, so all
we are saying is so.
So suppose that now we had
languages like Hindi, Bhojpuri,
Bengali.
So instead of putting them as
long as it is, you put them at
001010100, right?
You put the one at different
places.
I mean, are we looking at it
from this space and memory
optimization point of view?
Because the character would take
longer, whereas representing it
No, no, no, this is, let me put
it this way.
into no no.
This is this is what data
scientists have been using for a
long time as A1 hot encoding in
programming language.
So put them in categorical
attribute that way and so so
there are many algorithms that
they found is that they run
better.
So it's nothing to really giving
no giving no additional
information or no additional
logic.
So you will hear many times in
programming or someplace people
You are.
OK.
saying that I have done one hot
encoding, so don't be worried.
All they did is to put the
binaries.
OK.
Thank you.
I ideally if you're constrained
with the, I mean it a lot of
data we would avoid using one
hot encoding right?
Because they are attributes will
increase.
30 If no, no, it is not a lot of
data.
But suppose that if it is 3
attributes, so 010 is fine.
But what will happen?
Is suppose you have got a
something which can have take
possibly 50,000 possible values.
So that vector becomes very big.
Is it not?
Yes, right.
I mean the second approach was
better than I think where you
said, you know assign one value
to each like 1234 something like
Right, right.
Yeah, right.
that.
Right, right. Yes.
Alright, so now let us proceed
into the feature engineering.
So feature engineering is not a
big it's a sounds like a big
name, but it is not really a big
thing.
So all we are saying is that
when would be we have the data,
we have the data when applied to
the model, we rather call it as
a features.
That is how most of the data
scientists and most of the most
of the books refer to them.
So.
So The thing is that there is
the feature is what?
What?
Uh, we give it to the model for
the purpose of the modeling.
We give it to the program, so
don't really worry about this.
This is more of a nomenclature.
It is same as an attribute, but
some people say that attribute
that is given to the model I
would call it as a feature, but
don't worry about that.
So feature engineering by
feature engineering we are
saying is that what do we do
when we have too many features
or too few features or if we
think that the feature has to be
transformed.
So we need to we need to
consider a few things.
First thing is that when we have
many features we we we have to
recognize that the data science
algorithms generally fail.
They fail for very simple reason
that the many some of those
features will be having random
values and with those random
values they are going to confuse
the machine when it is computing
the distance and similarity.
Are we In Sync there?
Then we introduce irrelevant
values.
For example, we are talking
about got.
Suppose you need to sell in a a
fancy gadget and you are looking
for the customers who are likely
to buy your product.
So you also got the set of
customers who have got who
bought the product.
So now let us say only relevant
attribute is income, but instead
of stopping with income, you
thought that even the even the
age counts, the profession
counts and then the ZIP code of
the person counts.
So now in the process you have
created many attributes and now
you start computing the distance
between the various customers
and see who is likely to buy
based on the people who already
bought.
So you are going to get more
erroneous results.
Are we In Sync by introducing
irrelevant attributes and using
them for distance calculation?
Is going to create more
confusion rather than helping
us.
I'm saying straight away saying
that they are irrelevant
attributes, but they are
available so so, so many times
you have a data set.
The data sets will contain 200
attributes, but you are problem
may require really only 20 of
them.
So if you don't take the trouble
of filtering those 180, it is
likely that your algorithm will
be misled and give inconsistent
or inefficient results.
So so that is referred as a
phenomenon known as hugest
phenomenon.
This is also considered as a
curse of dimensionality by some
people, so when they
dimensionality increases, the
quality of results from the data
science process will reduce.
OK, so having understood that
let us proceed.
How do we handle that
redundancy?
So one of the ways we can handle
the redundancy is that so be me
get redundancy because we get
data from many sources or even
when it is from one source that
may have integrated data from
many places.
So we need to identify what is
derivable data.
If the data is derivable, we
should not use it straight away
and use it into the algorithm,
because the the the this data
can already be computed using
the other attributes, so it is
not going to add any value.
So.
So the other approach to find
the redundant attributes through
correlation analysis and
covariance analysis.
So we are going to look at that.
So the correlation analysis is
when we have and numerical data,
we can compute the correlation
coefficient witches witches also
so.
Referred as a person's movement,
so the formula is this.
So we have the attributes one
column which is AI, another
column which is BI.
So we want to see whether there
is a correlation between them.
So we compute the mean for both
the columns and apply this
formula and this will give us
the results in the range of 1
and minus one.
OK, this will be the range and
when it is 1 they are positively
correlated strongly positively
correlated and this is a
negatively correlated.
So when one increases, other
decreases.
So the correlation can also be
computed using a dot product.
So to do that you need to use
these two, so you'd have to
compute the jet score of A and
jet score of B, and then do a
dot product then.
Also you will get the
correlation.
Another closely related concept
to correlation is a covariance
in covariance in the
denominator.
No browser.
You will not use the Sigma and
Sigma.
And also also.
OK, so there is a question.
Yeah and.
Just a sort of here.
I just one confirmation in the
previous slide.
Yes.
There is a dot product which you
mentioned is.
Previous previous slide is this
slide right, yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, 40 point.
Yes, yes.
So dot product means what we are
mentioning right now here.
The dot predict we talked about
the cosine similarity.
First, we compute A dot product.
OK. Umm.
So now let us say, let us say
the vector a, right?
So let me let me put it.
So let me put it vector A I'm
representing it, let's say small
vector.
OK, so it is a A1A2A3 and vector
B is B1B2B3 and A dot BE is
simply A1 dot B1A1 multiplied by
B1 plus a 2 * B two plus a 3 * B
three.
That will be the dot product.
So we have seen that for cosine,
right?
The numerator.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. OK.
So rauser this this one just now
the in the slide E key there is
Hmm.
a.
Yeah.
So AKI is nothing but a K minus
mean by standard deviation A
which we were calculating the Z
score. Right?
Z score we calculated and then
another Z score.
Right, right.
We are calculating, so can I
understand that it's nothing but
multiplication of two different
Z score and which is going to
Yeah, that is correct.
yeah.
That is correct.
So which will give?
Yeah.
OK.
Got it.
Yeah, actually, actually, Mr
Saurav, you can look at the
Yes. OK.
formula.
So in the formula actually it is
already there.
So so it is just that we can
express that as a dot product.
Yeah.
Yeah, so, so this is this may
be, yeah.
Yeah, got it. Yeah.
And we can have like a
correlation, we have a
covariance, so covariance only
advantage with the covariance is
that it is easier to calculate.
You don't need to calculate the
Sigma only you need to calculate
the mean.
So because Sigma involves the
squares and square roots, so
this will be faster to compute.
So, but then the covariance can
only give the sign of the
change.
It is not going to give you the
magnitude.
Magnitude is not important, so
cosine covariance is going to
tell whether they're going to.
They have a positive relation or
negative relation, so you can
see that we have got the two
stocks and we have looking at
the stock prices over one week,
so Monday to Friday we have
taken the stock prices for two
stocks A&B and we are seeing
whether they have a positive
covariance or negative
covariance.
So we are seeing that they have
a positive covariance.
So what that means is that we
can predict that if a rises, the
B is also likely to rise.
OK.
And then then we have another
concept, which is that for
nominal data it is called Chi
square analysis.
Uh, so the chi squared analysis
is something.
Have you studied the chi squared
analysis already in your MFDS?
No, not OK.
Ohh no.
No, no.
OK.
OK, no problem.
No problem.
So what we do is that in Chi
Square this is for computing the
correlation.
For nominal data, this is for
computing the correlation for
nominal data, right?
So how do we compute so we
compute a cross tabulation
between the two variables?
Suppose that we have two
attributes, so one is 1
attribute is the person like
science fiction or not.
So for each person we have
surveyed 1500 people.
Uh.
1500 people.
And then what we did is that we
asked for two attributes.
Do you play chess?
So this is yes or no.
And then, like science fiction,
this is your son.
So we computed after we get the
data from the survey of for 1500
people, we have formulated the
cross tabulation cross
tabulation.
There are 450 people, like
science fiction or and out of
them 250 play chess and 200 do
not, and 1050 people do not like
science fiction.
Out of them, 50 people play
chess and 1000 people do not.
So now the question is that do
we think that there is a
correlation between playing
chess and liking science
fiction?
So when we have this type of
nominal attributes, we are
looking at the number of
possible values that the nominal
attribute can take.
So there is a concept called
degrees of freedom.
So this is count of rows minus 1
multiplied by columns minus one.
So why is that?
Why is it like this?
So, so.
So let me let me compute so to
explain the rows, explain the
degrees of freedom.
So let us say we have the data.
Which is like this.
So so one is play and not play
right and then like and not like
so we can we have the summary
four, 50,050 we have already got
the summary and then 300 and
1200.
So we don't have the core cross
relation between the two.
We do not have the relation
between the two.
We only got this summation of
both the data, so now let us say
I put this as 250.
So I put one of the values.
So now look at the other three
values.
Do you really need other three
values?
Other three values you can
derive right?
One value is given.
You can derive other three
values, so there is only one
independent value in the
correlation table.
Is that clear?
So that is why the degrees of
freedom is coming to one.
Uh, big.
Explain one second.
Again, Sir, this one.
I OK.
Uh, yes, Miss Surubi, what is
the question?
I didn't get your question.
Yeah, please explain the A
degree of freedom.
Once again, please so with
whatever example you have given
But no, no, no, no.
alright.
It.
Have you understood that once
251 of the one of these four
values, so one of these four
values is given?
So suppose that this is already
given.
This is these things are already
given because they are
independent of the other
attributes.
Umm.
So we these are only
representing one particular
attribute.
So now let me look at let me
share these four.
Umm.
I am shading the four attributes
with purple out of these four
attributes, 4 values.
I am saying that if one is
given, you can get the other
three.
Can you just convince yourself
that when one is given, you can
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
get the other right?
OK, that is all you need to do
so that is the degrees of
freedom.
So the degrees of freedom in
this case is 1.
So we are going to what we are
going to compute is that now we
will compute the observed
values.
These are the observed values,
so these are the observed
values, right?
No, what we say is that first
letter assume that there is
absolutely no correlation
between liking science fiction
and playing chess.
So then what are we expecting?
So these are two independent
random variables.
So when there are 450 people who
like science fiction, So what do
we expect in the relation of the
playing chess and not because
20% people play chess and 80%
people don't play chess?
So you expect that 20% of 450 is
90 and 80% of the 4:50 is 360.
So you expect 90 people should
play just and 360 people should
not play just similarly, 1050
people do not like science
fiction, so 20% is 210 and 80%
is 840.
So the within brackets we have
expected expected assuming.
No correlation.
So these two are completely
independent attributes.
So now we compute the chi
square, which is a comparison of
observed values with the
expected values.
So we are getting a chi square
score.
So this guy Square score will
help us decide whether there is
a.
So, given the degrees of freedom
one BS, look at only the first
row and what we say is that if
the chi square value is greater
than this is this is the
probability of null hypothesis.
Null hypothesis in disguise.
Square analysis is no
correlation.
So we are getting the null
hypothesis chi square value
greater than 10.
So what we are saying is that
the null hypothesis has a
strength less than .01, so that
is we can say with 99 greater
than 99% confidence that they
are correlated.
Are we In Sync?
Said from where?
Arvin.
Sir, can you can you repeat?
Uh.
Is that from where we are
deriving that expected value?
Expected value we have computed
assuming there is no
correlation, so they have to
follow the same.
So what we are saying is that
see see the the people who are
play chess and not play chess in
a typical population is 20% and
80%, right, Missouri.
You observed that right?
No, but how did we arrive at
that?
Uh, yes.
How how did we arrive at that 20
percent, 80% Sir.
Because we are thinking we we
think that this population is a
representative population for
playing chess and not playing
chess.
Ohio, OK.
So 1500 people out of them 300
places for 1200 don't play.
So we think that 20% people play
just and 2080% don't.
OK, OK.
Alright.
Mr B.
So out of four. Yeah.
Admin Singh, OK.
Yeah.
So out of four out of out of
450, we are keeping like that
20% like 90 in pages and 360 not
playing chess.
Yes, yes, that is the expected
values.
OK hmm.
Assuming that there is no
relation, there is no dependence
between these two.
So what we assume is that we
will follow a standard
distribution like any other like
the for playing chess.
We have the already the standard
values 2018.
So which is which is, which is a
which we call it as a pop
probability that we computed
from outside.
Uh, so that we assume that it
holds.
Hmm.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
So can you explain this?
How do we derive this number
92110 three 6840?
OK, 90 and 360 just now we
talked.
So is that still a problem?
Yeah.
19 So what we are saying is
first thing, let us assume that
this is a representative
population.
So 1500 is good enough to for
you to draw conclusions.
OK, so now you see the 300
people play.
OK.
Just 1200 people don't play just
so you can assume that
probability of playing chess is
20%.
Is that fine, Mr Romik?
Correct, right.
So now use the same thing to the
population which likes the
science fiction.
So there are 450 people who like
science fiction.
They should follow the same
distribution like 20% should
play cricket, play chess, right?
So 90 people should play just
among the 4:50.
Because because we are saying
that there is no impact of the
Can you please go back to the
slide, Sir?
one on the other.
So it will follow the same
population distribution.
Is that fine, Mr Romik?
Yeah.
Can you go back to slide please,
Sir?
Yes, yes.
So 250 -, 90 is.
No, no, don't worry.
Don't worry about 250 -, 90.
First, convince yourself that
the numbers within brackets, so
you are convinced that with the
if there is no relation between
the two.
This is what you will expect
because they will follow the
standard population 1500 people
20% and 80%.
So you'll get the same right.
So so far we concluded that the
20% of the population play chess
and 80% population don't play
chess.
Right, right.
Correct.
Yes.
So we assume the same pattern
for both the both both these
Now who, like.
OK, OK.
rows, right? Yes.
No, no, not 20.
Not no, no, no.
So.
20% of 454 fifty, yes, yes.
Of 450.
Or total sum.
The total at last.
OK, OK.
Yeah, total at last sum of row.
Yes.
OK.
And 20% of not like science is
again 20% of 1050 is 210.
OK.
Yes.
Then 80% of this OK.
So the Chi square formula is
this chi square formula.
We said the object would
expected.
I said I I we will take the
example.
So this is the example.
So this is how you compute
observed and expected observed
will be given.
Expected has to be computed and
then based on that you apply the
formula and you get the chi
square value and then you look
at the table and this table is
telling you that with 99%
greater than 99% counter because
Chi Square is more than 10.8.
So if it is 10.8, we are saying
that with the degrees of freedom
of 1, the null hypothesis has a
chance of only .001.
So alternate hypothesis that is
their correlated has a strength
of .999, so 99.9% confidence.
You can say that they're
correlated.
Uh, rouser, where in that table
it is lying.
I'm sorry I'm not so many data.
I'm not able to make out.
No, no, this is the first row,
first row, the column first
column is saying DF which is
degrees of freedom.
OK.
So we what we are saying is that
the degrees of freedom is
Yes, yes.
computed as one.
So with one degrees of freedom,
we are looking at the chi square
OK.
values and we are seeing that
the value we got is 500, which
is beyond the .001.
OK 10.8. Ohh.
It will be lesser than .001.
So we are concluding that at
least 99.9% confidence, we can
Anything.
say that they're correlated.
OK.
OK. OK.
OK, so so so the other point is.
So, Sir, are we expected to
remember these formulas and
when?
Yeah, the formula has to be
remembered.
So the numbers and the chi
square table, you don't need to
remember the formula has to be.
I'll let the formulas what we
discussed in the though the
Yeah, yeah, the formulas are
you.
calculations.
Yeah.
Yeah, right.
Right, you need to review them.
Yes, yes.
So it is this.
So at.
Is this the fix table?
Oh, oh, the table you have shown
in at last.
What table?
Yes.
Yeah, that is a fixed table.
Yet this one that.
It's something like log table.
Yeah, you just fix it.
It is fixed.
Table the guy square table.
You will get it.
You will get it in many you just
search for the web and hundreds
of websites will have.
Ohh OK.
So this is a fixed table and
you'll be happy to use this.
So I'm seeing I have few more
slides, but are you fine with
Whatever.
I said maybe 10.8 to 18.
another 10 minutes or?
What other values are
represented?
OK, I think I will stop here.
Only just I will answer the
questions and close it.
Yeah.
Tell me you have some more
question.
Go ahead.
But thank you.
What is the question?
Alright so.
I said can you just explain that
table once?
Like what exactly those data
sets are representing?
Uh, this ones up?
OK, Mr Desh RATHNA is.
I want to see the chi square
table.
Is that correct?
This table is what you are
asking right?
Yes, Sir. Correct.
Or you are asking some other
table.
Correct.
So from formula we derive that
the chi square value is 500 plus
No, no.
Correct the same table.
I just wanted to understand.
right?
So, so how and where it is
fitting and how?
Yes, this is the formula that
gets you chi square.
Yeah.
Yes.
So we got it 507.
And then yes.
Now how does it fit and how?
How we can get the conclusion
out of this table that 500?
Yeah.
So that 505 hundred seven with
what we are comparing Sir, how
is that?
No.
We are comparing actually with
the 10.8 to 8 is greater than
10.828.
See suppose that you got a chi
square value of eight.
Then you say that it is fitting
between .005 and .002.
You can see that are you able to
see these numbers?
Right, yes.
Yeah.
So if you got a chi square of
eight, you can say that it is
between .005 and .002.
Then you will say that it is
99.8% to 99.5%, but then what we
got is a high.
That is greater than 10.8 to 8,
so we are using only part of the
CHI square table because the chi
square table can go up to any
number on the right side.
I mean, it can go up to 1000
also, but beyond 10.8 to 8, what
Umm.
we are saying is that we already
got 99.9% confidence.
So 500 means definitely it is
more than this confidence.
So does it means that the
probability of playing the chess
OK so.
versus watching that science
fiction movie is almost same,
right?
What?
What it doesn't mean like 99%,
right? What?
No, there is a.
So what we are saying with
confidence is that you cannot
ignore playing chess when
somebody you also already have
the values of.
Sorry.
So what we are saying is that
whenever you already know the
that person is playing chess,
that is significantly impacting
whether the person will like
science fiction or not, and vice
versa.
When you know the one variable,
the other variable is
OK.
significantly impacted.
It doesn't mean that they are
same, but while we are saying is
it is significantly impacted.
OK, sorry I interrupted someone.
So I have one question, Sir.
If somebody else has asked.
Can I ask?
Yes, yes.
They said I have one question.
So if I understood correctly
what you are trying to explain
here is that it's basically more
on hypothesis testing S and
those related to categorical
data, right?
Absolutely Mr plugin.
That is correct.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
So you brought in a new word, so
now I hope nobody else will ask
again.
Explanation of hypothesis
testing.
So I I didn't bring it because
hypothesis testing is no big
deal.
So so that is just a word that.
You use things you used in
couple of slide before this word
hypothesis.
A hypothesis.
I used the word hypothesis.
OK, OK. Yeah.
Right, Sir.
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
So can you go back to this?
Just that guy square formula.
Sky Square formula this one.
Just I want to say, yeah.
This one right?
Yeah, this. Yeah.
Yeah, this one, OK.
Thank you, Sir.
Alright, so are there any
questions?
OK, so if there are no
questions, yeah.
So, Sir, Sir.
Yeah.
Yeah, I am, missus.
One last question, so in in the
previous slide, Sir, in the
Yeah, go ahead.
previous slide, observed means
is that can we consider 1500
No, Joe's observed is actually
the survey result survey result,
observed no observed is fine
not.
yes.
OK.
OK, OK.
Hello Sir.
Quick question again, again
again, it's related to the quiz,
Yes, yes, yes.
if you don't mind.
Like can we expect like which
until which lecture we need to
revisit and then we need to go
through.
Is there any?
Can you can you elaborate on
that?
No, no, it all the things that
are recovered till the last
class.
So that is I think we are
planning it on 31st, right?
So maybe thing till now and
possibly something's if even the
next class.
Is there any discount for New
Year?
Uh no.
I mean.
Why are you so much concerned?
I don't know the they they
won't.
They they, I'm sure you will do
well.
See.
Please see the the interest that
you are asking you are taking,
so just spend a few hours on the
lectures or just browsing some
some things in their textbooks
so I'm sure you'll do that.
OK, great.
Thanks. Sure.
Alright, so if there are no
other questions then I'll close
the session.
Key.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you.
And happy holidays, everyone.
Bye.
Thank yourself.
Thank you.
Happy already and I think this
month.
Thank you.